1990 dans un quartier défavorisé de
nancy à l'école un constat alarmant
l'équipe pédagogique de nombreux enfants
ne mangent pas à leur faim les apports
en produits laitiers sont très nettement
insuffisante également les légumes et
les fruits sont pas consommés problèmes
de santé moment d'inattention
le point commun entre les enfants
concernés c'est qu'ils ne mangent pas à
la cantine faute de moyens en 1996 le
phénomène touche les écoles collèges et
lycées de quartiers défavorisés de la
france entière en particulier en
banlieue parisienne à aulnay sous bois
par exemple dans ce collège
seuls 5 % des élèves sont en demi
pension à cette recherche 860 par
trimestre encore se séparant d'accord
mais là c'est parti
la cantine trop cher alors certains
enfants déjeunent à la maison des repas
souvent mal équilibré 850 francs pour un
trimestre je ne suis pas sûr à l'heure
actuelle que les parents dépensent cette
somme pour leurs enfants
il ya des enfants qui rentrent chez eux
pour avoir une assiette de pâtes
ça c'est certain philippe face à
l'ampleur du phénomène les écoles
proposent des solutions aux parents la
vie est difficile dans des femmes
certaines familles ben on a des
difficultés à ce moment là je reçois vos
parents pour essayer de voir comment on
peut les aider à payer la cantine mais
difficile pour bien des parents
d'accepter cette main tendue
question de dignité en la filmant
genedigi obligé de demander quelque
chose pour pas pu manger midi il se sait
des fichiers ça c'est difficile oui les
cantines scolaires déserté un homme a
étudié le phénomène philippe farine du
conseil économique et social la
conclusion de son rapport en 1996
seule une volonté politique réglera le
problème
je crois qu'on n'a pas traité avec
suffisamment de vigueur et de rigueur
ce problème de la cantine scolaire et de
la demi pension qui ne peut plus être
laissée à l'appréciation des sens et des
autres il y a un devoir public
d'intervenir dans ce domaine à vrai dire
certains départements proposait déjà des
subventions pour rendre la cantine gras
8 ou presque en 1998 face aux alertes
répétées le gouvernement l'ensemble plan
de 250 millions de francs 50 millions
d'euros versés aux écoles pour alléger
le coût de la cantine
[Musique]